let me start with the big news here I
heard you got a new flip phone yeah yeah
upgrade upgrade okay
wait is this an antique that you bought
I didn't know they made flip phones
anymore no they're still in production
baby do your teammates give you grief
about this yes all the time it's
honestly the joke is getting a little
old it's played out
gru a modern technology guy I mean you
went to school in the Silicon Valley
there yeah I know I am NOT a Luddite I
appreciate all the comforts of modern
technology but I enjoy flip phone and
it's a personal choice I like it I like
it
how different was the offseason this
offseason as opposed to last offseason
yeah very different you know in every
offseason I think it's a little
different but you know we came off the
season and we didn't do so well and so
that has a different spell on it and
also you know being injured throughout
the end of the season there's much more
focus of a you know rehab focus and
getting back healthy and you know
usually after season take a couple weeks
off and travel and go on vacation and
you know that certainly wasn't the case
this past year I went right into the
skin getting into rehab and training and
getting ready for the season what's the
difference between playing hurt and
playing injured that's a good question I
think everybody and then FL is gonna
play hurt you know once you're past a
week three I think everybody's playing
hurt through something and then playing
injured is this not fun it's just not
fun and you know hopefully I you know I
think our doctors and trainers on the
coast do a great job is keeping us you
know as healthy as possible and making
sure that we understand the risks of
going out there but plane injured is no
fun do you hide injuries do I hide
injuries I don't think I do I think I
communicated us as honestly and
forthrightly with with our training
staff and coaches throughout my career
you know I wouldn't say I've had
injuries I can actually I can feel your
grin when I ask that question because
instead maybe I don't talk about my
injuries to you they
oh well no I don't I don't blame you I'm
just talking about the coaching staff
like would you hide it you know if they
said are you hurt and then you knew if
you said yes they were taking you out
you probably might fib uh you know I can
see where you might at some point but uh
not until you're in the situation you
answer the question alright have they
told you to stop making tackles no
there's not told me to stop making
tackles they just told me to stop
throwing I saw where the Bengals told
Andy Dalton stop making you know trying
to make tackles when you throw these
interceptions but I mean there's
something there's like this animalistic
linebacker feel it looks like whenever
you throw one that you're gonna go and
you want to plaster somebody you know
I've always thought that this is if I
didn't give effort to try and right or
wrong in a sense that I'd be severely
disappointed in myself and so uh I was I
was taught how to tackle on a tackle
properly at a young age you know my
coaches so I guess there's you know
there's some training in that nice he's
a Andrew Luck of the Colts joining us on
behalf of a DIRECTV we'll get to that
coming up here in a moment we were
looking coming out of high school
rivals.com had you the fourth-ranked
drop back quarterback do you remember
the three guys ahead of you I do not
blame gabart Dayne Crist and Mike
Glennon all great guys but how
competitive were you with that with your
ranking did you care where you were no I
did I did not care I did not I just
wanted to go play college football and
never gotten a chance to go to Stanford
that's all that I cared about
expectations this year
are they any different than any other
year no they're not every I remember
walking into the Colts building my
rookie year and being told by Dwight
Freeney Robert Mathis Reggie Wayne and
what the expectations as a Colt were and
it was to make the playoffs and give
yourself a chance to win the Super Bowl
yeah and that's not still the same
expectation but you were lucky to have
those veterans there when you got there
what kind of what kind of impact did
they have on you
now they were huge they you know they
did definitely all different
personalities those three guys and then
still Adam Vinatieri and Robert are
obviously still here but they showed me
they showed all the young guys py Hilton
Dwayne Allen how to be pros I mean those
guys were when I liked it and Reggie was
was he was still playing at an
incredibly high level and you could see
why he took care of his body mentally he
was as sharp as any wide receiver
you know Robert Mathis is routine and
the way they approached football was a
very professional manner through a very
professional manner and it rubbed rubbed
off on us I know you're working with
DIRECTV so it's your turn to play the
role of Peyton Manning here let's hear
the plug that's fun ya know DIRECTV it's
awesome 20 years now it's been the
exclusive home to NFL Sunday Ticket and
I think probably the coolest thing this
year is if you don't have a satellite
you're eligible or go to two to four
year University eligible for for
streaming online at NFL Sunday Ticket
dot TV so you can get all your all your
favorite live out-of-market games that
way we should save your team grilling up
favorite team growing up with the
Houston Oilers my dad was a quarterback
on the Oilers from 82 through 87 he
backed up Archie Manning and Warren Moon
I mean my second favorite team was the
frankfurt galaxy of NSL europe same life
well who was the quarterback for
frankfurt galaxy well I think Jake
Delano Jake Delhomme was a quarterback
for a car maybe one offseason in
Frankfurt Polizei my favorite Oh grew up
overseas for for nine years
my dad was working for NFL Europe so I
remember getting in the car with him and
driving up to Amsterdam and go and see
Kurt Warner play for the Amsterdam the
Admirals I actually joke with with Venna
Terry about that because she's spent the
96 season with the Amsterdam Admirals
and I was like a seven year old over
there are we watching a game of his do
you speak another language I'm I can get
by in German I need a little work though
all right now we have somebody on the
staff
Paulie my producer who does a poor
imitation of you are you are you game
for listening to Paulie do his andrew
luck impersonation absolutely kallu okay
so Paul over over Paulie while we're
willing Paulie are you okay because
you've done this before with us but now
with Andrew here I want to see how you
are under pressure this is a two-minute
drill glad to do it Dan back here on
behalf of directing TV Sunday Ticket got
my brand-new 18 t flip phone how I done
don't care the McAfee makes fun of it at
all I can take him I can I'll tackle him
smart mouth special teamer franker
galaxy favorite team and go cards
Sunday Ticket
Oh aye Cardinal oh that's the only part
of it that you let me be honest though
because he does this all the time thanks
for being Explorer high effort marks
high effort mark I appreciate that
hey great to talk to you thanks for
joining us hopefully we'll talk during
the season and thanks for joining us
absolutely take care thanks Rodney I'm
sweating yeah I'm sweating yeah what a
good sport he was but you're doing this
impersonation exaggerated and then when
he gives you that answer would you think
of it oh not a bad job by Paulie see
students although I did what a good
sport he is oh nice dude I was in a full
sweat good natty know I had to ask the
question
I couldn't just spring it on him I I had
to do a hey we got a guy and it's not a
very good impersonation of you say that
was the key right there you said it I
say he does a poor impression
yeah and that sort of right no way
resembles you yeah effort so he could
have also said if it such a poor
impersonation why should we bother you
know listening to it they were doing
let's just move on and talk football
that might be one of the toughest
questions of it the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience